estas imágenes fueron tomadas momentos
después de que el ejército israelí
lanzara múltiples ataques aéreos en la
franja de gaza entre las víctimas
civiles esta niña de 5 años fuera de la
morgue cientos de personas reunidas
esperando identificar a sus familiares
el grupo militante yihad islámica dijo
que israel había declarado la guerra al
pueblo palestino
esto es una violación y un desprecio
hacia todos los esfuerzos que se han
hecho en los últimos días con el fin de
restablecer la calma hemos respondido
positivamente a estos esfuerzos pero el
enemigo ha sido como siempre traicionero
he llevado a cabo esta incursión
traicionera responderemos claramente
este crimen con toda nuestra fuerza
los ataques preventivos iban dirigidos
contra un alto comandante del grupo
extremista se producen pocos días
después de la detención de uno de los
miembros del grupo durante una redada en
cisjordania ocupada teniendo un ataque
de venganza israel cerró todos los pasos
fronterizos y restringió la circulación
de civiles cerca de la frontera el
primer ministro israelí dijo que los
ataques se lanzaron en base amenazas
concretas
israel llevó a cabo una precisa
operación antiterrorista contra una
amenaza inmediata nuestra lucha no es
con la gente de gaza la jihad islámica
es una representación iraní que quiere
destruir el estado de israel y matar a
israelíes inocentes
israelís
israel no está interesado en una campaña
amplia en gaza pero tampoco la teme
al caer la noche los militantes
palestinos de gaza respondieron en
represalia disparando más de un centenar
de cohetes desde el territorio